[Music]
okay guys we have the new magic they're
getting instructed midnight hans sweat
boosters in the house uh thanks to
visitors of the course who has sent this
to us pretty early and we're gonna unbox
it for you right now this is pretty cool
we have 30 set boosters inside but
we also have
the commander deck from lenoir itself
she features the coven mechanic
and the um i would say the sentiment in
the office now is that she's actually
pretty underpowered let's be honest here
it's not something that we'll be looking
forward to but we'll have to see what
the rest of cards and how it all comes
together in the commander set itself but
i think the highlight here is they said
boosters but before that we are unboxing
on a very nice dragon shield playmat
here and
ted what do you think about this the
drying shoe playmats they're all very
unique uh they
are all custom made and the artwork is
also
all
commissioned by different artists so
this is not art that you will find in
actual magic cards okay um only on
dragon shield products so it feels
smooth it looks good so get some of the
dragon shield mats for yourself okay and
just nice if you can bring in the set
boosters once again yep it's a very nice
matching color i think it is an orange
again for the october period
well it's midnight hunt so
you know it's all about uh knights and
werewolves and vampires
and so yeah the orange fits very well in
the blue as well okay let's get to it
let's get maybe let's get it all off
yeah so then we can put the box on one
side
awesome all right well it really looks
like gold man this is for money natural
paper money
okay what are we looking out for okay
we're gonna hope for some of the mythic
rares um they're gonna be some new
planeswalkers
uh the ferry is coming back okay after
being away for a few sets
of ferry is normally uh considered a
very strong commander
and looks like looking at the spoilers
he is going to be used quite a lot in
the next standard all right and then um
we also have aurelien another
command another planeswalker so she's
going to be a day by mike brown
card which is a new mechanic in this set
so depending on what time of the day it
is it will come in on either front or
back side okay yeah cool let's get to it
okay let's do our first back
i don't want to rip any of these cards
careful just dump it through one side to
be so nice yeah okay so we also have the
always start the art card
nice okay that's what's good yep okay
[Music]
our comments and our rare is
oh it's a mythic rare wow
nice
looks like it's a zombie card
two three
so we're gonna put it right here
okay and what do you have for the
following actually no
these are set boosters so we have the
four oil so it's a common electric
revelation
additional cost across this card is
discarded card and draw two cuts so
quite similar to other cards but there's
a flashback which you can cast from the
graveyard okay yeah
nice let's put this on one side to
manage it a bit but we'll keep the rest
in frame
[Music]
okay all right land and then go through
the comments
comments comments where light up the
night sorcery it looks like it deals
damage to any target
really good and it gets additional one
damage if it's a future okay
okay it's it's pretty good if you can
actually launch it early in the game
itself
and it can cast it again loyalty
correct oh but at the cost of using the
flash uh things of course things will
control well it's flexible because you
have the axe there so you can cast it
for low damage or higher damage so
probably in the later game if you have
more wanna you can really shoot for more
damage and then deals to any target
means you can also go to your face okay
directly there
okay thanks you need that to uh
get past the enemy's defenses that's
okay not the greatest but we are getting
there actually that's a good i think
that's a good rare at least for game
game wise you think so yeah it can be
quite i think it's quite strong it has
flashbacks so means you can cast it
again okay so after one time you can do
it again you know
okay
so set boosters usually they are themed
at the start um based on
different cards whoa
extended this is i think the showcase
frame so every set nowadays there's a
specific showcase frame and for me night
hunt it's kind of this like
it's a bit more gothic then a bit more
witchery type of
you get a lot of the greenery that comes
in it looks like it's like rotting trees
actually right so it's you know
kind of fits the theme of like
werewolves who appear in the jungle
oh there's two of them okay wow okay
well there's three of them
yeah so okay yeah i'm not sure how the
packing packaging goes here oh this is
our rare can't stay away
return entire creature cut with mana
velar trio that's the graveyard so it's
like a reanimation and he has flashback
again so it looks like flashback is
going to be a quite a consistent team
theme in this
set yeah
can't stay away white and blank once
again i've been playing quite a bit of
online and really what is really strong
with getting cards out of the graveyard
and together paired with black reminds
me of the dungeon mechanic that we saw
yes correct with four cartoon realms yes
right
for that flashback it's an older
mechanic so basically that's coming back
and it's considered quite strong yeah
okay
but we have our file oh we have a foil
rare
wow guys flame reservoir artifact
so it looks like when you cast internal
sorceries you put a counter and then
after that you can remove counters to
deal damage during target
or excel
top cut off your library and play that
card so she's pretty nice for red okay
yeah okay let's go to the next pack
i think for all our rest we better put
it in a sleeve quickly just in case
foreign at the back this one we have the
what's this one we have here the connex
this is the connex art card that we have
yeah and i believe there's also there'll
also be matching playmates right for
each of the other cards we have to see
what did we get from
dragon shield everything's been pretty
generous but let's move on i mean
there's so many designs you know but i
believe like each art
hey we got a card for
the same the same one right now the
knight yeah
floral land these are beautiful
oh what's this this is from the
commander box in
arizona
but it's actually found in the commander
set okay
so
i think in the the other commando box
with zombies this is one of the cards
inside but so you can also open all
these in the set boosters okay yeah
showcase frame nice
oh an automatic rare this one is i think
one of the top for this set wow okay
mono blue layer disciple of the drum
very interesting spells can't be counted
so
you can't counter the opponent's spells
in a pony can't count your spells okay
but you guys find it because in blue if
you're playing mono blue usually you
want to be countering other yeah
so how you do you think this will
actually be combo with
um so it gives all your instance and
sorcery's flashback so me like
wait i know meal decks
you can't stop the meal
kasha's hideous laughter probably yeah
you know you can really cast it from
your graveyard after you oh my god so
disgusting
so potentially after you know maybe
because four times it costs eight times
okay my friends let's put this into the
sleeve straight away
for uncommon
oh and this is the list card oh we
should mention it once i guess so in the
set boosters
there's a chance of getting cuts from
all the sets okay and this is a curated
list of cards called the list and you
can tell by the this james walker symbol
yeah awesome some of these are worth a
lot but some of these are actually not
that much
we were so and
we were so taken away by liar that we
just pushed aside oh right eloi
yeah okay so what do we have oh not yet
not yet
fateful absence oh this is a great
removal spell
destroyed atari creature or planeswalker
oh social media
yeah that's very cheap and
quite rarely has this they have a bit
more control but not destroyed correct
correct and so a lot of people have been
saying they will be stuck you start
using this in commander so it could be a
commander staple
for a comment
or another this card so i'm coming look
at this layer probably nothing much
is not so sweet
cool man let's start with the comments
or comments
oh this is also from the midnight uh hun
commander set you can tell by the symbol
it's actually different yeah so this is
a rare so pretty much we got a free rare
i guess
ooh giza glorious resurrector
legendary name ninjas yeah this one
especially i think has been uh getting a
lot of buzz in the spoilers because it's
quite a strong it can be quite a strong
commander so whenever a creature
opponent controls the diet excellent and
at the beginning you can take all those
creatures and put it into
control
so it's quite scary it's kind of like
third grade at any time
um anytime the creature would die
opponents which are you exiled but only
during your upkeep you will take those
creatures ah okay and again they mean
they don't they don't last permanently
on your battlefield correct they can't
block and they can basically once you
attack they have to be sacrificed i love
the grid
steals people's things yes so this is
this also the same still people's things
okay one common okay cool okay let's put
it on one side
so 3 mana 2 3 menace and day bound okay
we can see the black and the green
showcase common uh showcase cards are
actually quite different quite
differently i think they
they overlay the color okay onto the
frame as well so this one is a double
double-sided card it can transform
ah this is the d-bomb
nightbound mechanic so how would you
actually play this with sleeves then
you would have to take it out again
that's what i was thinking
so that's why some people like double
sleeve so that when they take it out
they don't
actually like damage the cards
double sleeve making meaning like they
have a one sleeve uh-huh and then they
put it in the bigger sleeve which is
like the dragon shoe sleeve got it yeah
so it's so called like inner sleeves and
outer sleeves
whereas graveyard trespasser tree tree
human werewolf can transform
it's okay but i think the other side is
the one that's interesting is it i think
usually the nightbound side is a little
bit more powerful but then you have to i
think go through some hoops to
basically get to the night okay yeah so
not sure how that will play out yet in
games
right okay
[Music]
this is the face commander for the other
commander set okay yeah we helped it's a
zombie so-called zombie commander all
right yeah this is
actually considered quite strong so
i'm going to try it out myself as well
oh
rare is suspicions of duplicity second
rear of the pack
exchange control of two thai creatures
you don't control
so if your opponent has two pictures you
can kind of like exchange wait then is
our is a commander rare as well
oh yeah it's also a commander so
actually we still have one more one more
oh should you travel again
oh this is our sloga the over slime
interesting haven't seen this much but
looks like 33 blue green
place with lens in the graveyard and you
can put plus one person counters
on it okay wait i'm noticing whoa okay
foil rare
so you got four rares
sorry
four and one pack oh that's amazing i
think that's the good part about set
boosters is that you can get this kind
of like super crazy okay uh happenings
and it's good to open on camera yeah
it's proof that we did it you know
okay let me put this into a sleeve
let me help you manage it okay
[Applause]
we haven't hit any of the planeswalkers
yet so kind of like camera
a natural growth it's a rare this is a
considered powerful one oh yes this is
very awesome and so it doubles power and
toughness of your creatures well right
insane crazy well uncommon okay
okay let's go on to our unpacking
continue on
never thought you would get tired
opening packs right never it's really
it's really fun i think it's like gotcha
cause you never know what you're gonna
get right
thirsty adversary two mana two two haste
and then you can pay mana when it enters
the battlefield okay um
you get plus one plus encounters and you
can also exile
cards uh
okay like instantaneous sorceries one of
the three or lessons honestly there's a
lot of tags in this card
so
basically
uh you pay mana and depending on how
much money you pay you get some benefit
one of which is put personal personal
counters or also uh copy spells from
your graveyard okay without paying the
cost this doesn't look too broken at the
moment correct but you don't really know
yet how
players can confuse it and this is only
when it appears right i mean enters the
battlefield right it's not like a
perpetual
buff like that true so on first glance
it's not really that broken because you
have to pay the mana uh to activate it
so it depends on how much mana you have
yeah it might not be
that of that many and if you're playing
red do you really want to have so much
lens as opposed to have many creatures
to come on the ground if you're playing
that approach yeah i think normally you
want to be fast but maybe in the later
game maybe you can like generate some
value by recasting instant sorcery cards
uh depending on what you have in your
graveyard it can help you
kind of turn the tide turn the tide yeah
okay
awesome
yeah this one we got to sleeve it up
don't worry i'm managing it for you yeah
okay foil comment
quite a bit here let's do some
housekeeping okay so it looks good
very messy yes
the funny thing is that all these are
rare so actually they all have value
yeah
you don't want to just like throw them
away
okay
oh this is a new oh this is a slime lens
oh yeah and this is a borderless version
so
sometimes you get these in the set
boosters not very common actually okay
so pretty blue black yeah blue black is
a lot uh i'm playing a lot of ropes
right now rogue deck blue and black is
the ones and
enters the fuel attack unless you
control two or more other lens is
actually pretty good it's not yeah these
days you've seen blends with sky lens
lens with the gain you like this one is
a bit more slightly faster slow length
correct correct yeah
oh where sludge monster
looks like the 5.5
it doesn't look very exciting but uh
as well a few attacks but a slime
counter whatever you can okay so they
with some counters they lose all
abilities and become two twos okay we've
not seen stuff with other slime com
counters yet yes i don't think so so
probably is the only one here so let's
put the land down the sludge monster
more common common okay cool
i mean do we have to go already i think
kind of way are we halfway
quite a bit oh no we still have quite a
bit of halfway yeah which is good news
because i really would like to see some
planeswalkers
till the dawn hard primes are rare
looks like protection from werewolves
and cuban features to control can tap to
add one mana of any color so many
legendaries you're seeing yeah
i think they they usually have quite a
legendaries these days to uh
feel the
feel the commander for me oh this is a
list card mythic rare
they're doing pretty good yeah not bad
although i don't know what's the value
of this though you know sometimes even
if it's matic rare
uh it's actually may not be worth much
okay depending on in the meta right in
the matter yeah
if it's semitic where i'm not
complaining
oh and we should mention that the list
um changes every set these numbers yeah
they kind of like add and take out cards
so it's not always the same
right of harmony instant when a creature
on
so you could chain off like a
a storm count or a combo
this is okay
[Laughter]
what's so good about this card
okay so four mana for fall loyalty so
not bad on the course um
if you do the plus one you can tap one
tap a target artifact picture or land
and if it's your own you can untap and
with
opponents
it's just a tap and
you gain two life
so
it's basically like control in blue
white you are you want to control the
opponents okay so you're basically like
tapping down his stings and so that he
can attack or block or if you need to
untap your own things that's fine as
well you can use it to have your own
land use get more mana okay and also
gain life
he doesn't have much natural protection
i think blue has this
i think unlike let's say loft the spider
queen
she has like spiders that come out to
her they have reach yes and they can
block yeah
you can't really get he's gonna have a
thing a bit of a trick here but if you
don't have your defense defenses in
place correct correct yeah like in the
past the previous the fairies they have
a way of protecting himself
uh this one not so much but still the
abilities are pretty good and if you can
get to the ultimate you get an emblem
and have all permanence you control
doing each opponent's untapped step so
that means your defenses are back up
again yeah they're always back up
because uh you know you can untap and
then cast more stuff okay and you draw
cards
straight away holy
what's the chances guys we got it on
camera yeah come on okay let's get this
all out of the way
the fury is the one that is king right
now center center stage right yeah
do you remember the forgotten realms to
try to open the tianjin but we couldn't
well this time we did it we did it guys
okay all right
back to reality wait wait i think we
skipped we skipped something earlier or
something
oh no this is the
rare from the commander set pigeon
subdirect so it's a reanimate spell
and you can flashback as well
okay but target opponent oh interesting
so basically you are giving the opponent
a creature oh under your control uh
so but they choose which creation yeah
it's okay because they get to choose
yeah
where is danick pirates apprentice it's
a transform card so you can
it can come back from the graveyard
so i think some people have said this
could be good in control decks as well
it's probably interfering cards and
graveyards can't be targets of spells or
abilities and we saw that with the uh
great
i really love those lens i probably
got to admire them later
burn down the house for your rares it's
like a choice car you guys do you fight
damage to each creature or each place
rocket or create three double tokens
it's okay it's okay it's not bad
actually
for a comment uncommon okay this wasn't
a very good pack yeah only one yeah
like this whole power here is it's a bit
insane no but it's okay yeah
it will showcase out so nice oh
smoldering another rare
zero four
you cast instance of sorceries put ember
counters and then if you have seven or
more you can transform
into a dragon
so on first glance not super powerful oh
yeah obviously you gotta put counters on
it every time i see eggs it
[Music]
[Laughter]
ending number one correct
okay nice
oh
another legendary creature okay
so this is like a damage reduction in
damage increase actually okay quite
interesting if a spell would deal damage
to you or another permanent control
prevent that damage
so any burn spells prevent what yeah
okay so you can actually creatures can
so if the creatures attack you then
that's not a spell yeah that's a
creature rate tends to have quite a bit
of stuff that requires you to damage
yourself right in some ways
sometimes at cost yeah i mean if you're
against the rate opponent that will deal
damage to you and then this one if
you're playing red if your spell would
you damage your opponent you'd use plus
one so actually you can use your great
spells and it combines with the card the
spoiler that we had
yeah yeah yeah
in some ways the video hold them back
okay okay this was an okay pack
yeah normal normal yeah
i think we had a very good run in
content yeah we had a good start
all right
this is a nice it's a
i don't know what to call this but it
looks like some kind of edge foil or
cold foil
whereby the lines are
foiled
and it's in this black and white
version
so this is actually the rare that we
pulled before the trimar tree tree
people
oh we put the normal one just ah okay
let's just find it
oh that's right yeah so this is the
alternate art version
oh i remember the over slime one when we
talked about slime counters yeah yeah
here we go here we go
let's see the difference in it
so it's actually very different the art
is totally different
um
as you can see the artists are different
ones nipples gregory one is
robbie trevino
so
it's totally different and they put it
in black and white
wow it's very nice so to to i guess to
follow the theme of midnight okay
we haven't seen much of these uh
versions
you're the expert man
no i mean in this we haven't seen we
haven't seen anything
so this is the first time we've got a
lot of the showcase frames
what are you doing here what are commons
doing here
get out get
out
hey but some comments actually
can be worth some money okay but here we
are looking at all the good stuff okay
all right more planeswalkers please we
already got teferi we won
ireland or ren and seven how rare is
bloodline culling are they give a
creature minus five minus five or two
plus minus two minus two is a very good
nuke for three months yeah it gives you
a choice so you can either do a board
nuke for tokens or uh minus five minute
five to one
future tokens get minus two minus two
it's good
get out of the way
so annoying right it's a good song okay
for our comments okay
okay heart plan
okay showing too much
oh okay this
is so similar to the one we put earlier
the shipwreck marsh yeah this is the
blue white version but
not normal normal frame this is extended
frames yeah
well common
goblin lore is our this card man the
artist the the retro frame is looking
retro man this is the original magic
frame so i still have a soft spot for
this yeah okay i wish they would remake
it oh no it's just a bit bent but it's
all right
oh yeah a little bit i don't know how it
came out of the way yeah sometimes maybe
i noticed that the art cards for
something it's actually glossy cards we
didn't see this was it the same in uh
adventures or gotten right i believe it
was the same okay i'm not sure why but
they yeah they print the art cards in a
little glossier
actual part
maybe it looks shiny i guess
[Music]
we have a few more boosters to go
we're going into our last third i think
storm the festival
green rare sorcery look at top five
cards put up to two permanents with one
of value five or less onto the
battlefield oh so basically you get two
free things but provided what you get
what
you want one yeah
for six months six months
yeah to put up to 10 10.
yeah okay it's okay and he has flashback
it has flashback yeah so
archmage
also in the
uh alternate art which you saw with uh
the land slogan yeah so good
but this is a foil foil
special art card
and it's a rare i think the only really
top dish is to get it uh no no i would
say floral meeting special yes
borderless like the ferry has a
alternate art version so if you get that
okay yeah
this is so cool
yeah okay let me put it into the sleeve
as well okay
go ahead go ahead yep
cool dragon shield mythic rare gerund
corrupted bishop
two three human cleric there's a lot of
tanks again yeah and there's a better
few another or another non token here
when you control dice lose one life and
create a one one token
two target human control against
lifelink
and
the last part is quite interesting
because
if you have exactly 13 life and you play
six mana then you transform him
from
six six
demon flying trampoline
sega creature
troll car i'm pretty sure this guy here
is uh this is derek
jaren
he's looking at the demon so i think
you're right yeah pretty cool so
french wait what's the abilities flying
trample live playing sacrifice another
creature draw a cut actually that's very
strong okay second part yeah but it's
very hard to transform him because you
need exactly 13 and you already get a
lot of tokens with this uh character
itself so you have a really poor
resources to sacrifice right
yeah and you also lose one life when
when another non-token human enters so
actually you can try and
uh plan it out so that you can get to 13
life engineering yeah okay but he's very
strong we definitely need to sleeve him
up oh okay slave instant sleeve yeah and
we got a this card again this is scary
chrome
not scarecrow but scared chrome
yeah i'm not sure on the value of this
but uh it's a rare so yeah
[Music]
come on jeffery fury
well we already have the two free oh
four island
shiny that's nice yeah
briar bridge tracker
two tree and vigilance and there's
battlefield investigate where you create
a clue token
as long as you control your token it
gets plus two plus zero so essentially
it's like a three mana four tree
vigilance yeah
so okay yeah
for our column
it's okay it's okay
i wonder how will this actually see play
we need to investigate it deeper but
it's okay index that uh use investigate
so they create tokens which can
sacrifice to draw a card
uh then they come into
ucl it can synergize well
and it's only one token that she gets
plus two passes not per token correct
yeah so not not overpowered
mass of
chisel brand equipment equip features
flying and lifelink and when it dies you
may pay x life for excess of power if
you do draw x cards
it's okay that's okay but this draw x
cards could be good but you have to pay
life yeah
um
i would say black has a difficulty when
it comes to drawing cards um
in general as compared to blue but this
is a good option for them to really get
the machine going right yeah usually
they have a drawback when they want to
draw cards yeah by paying life
for uncommon oh and under this
towards the end yep
only one planeswalker so far siphon
inside it's a rare for two
mana blue black look at the top two
cards of opponent's library extra one of
them and you may look and play them as
long as it means excel um flashback too
so you can do it it's a good time yeah
is the key mechanic in this yeah it
looks like it's one of the
more prominent mechanics right
okay
well common
this is a rare
and it's got the alternate art
this is cool and white only thing is not
foil exactly it's normal yeah if you
actually if you flicker it in the light
yeah you can see that of a h yeah i
don't know whether they call it foil but
it seems like it's embossed okay
so
you think she's good
she is another verse there was a
previous liasa which is also an angel
with flying life ring this one
it's a bit different it
helps you return cuts to your hand when
they're dying just and
uh opponents creatures get excelled
instead of going to the graveyard
especially quite strong yeah so very
strong recycling when it comes to white
once again
you can never kill a white creature
prefer on the battlefield yeah
rare
crafted identity
and charming aura this guy looks like
nucleus cage man
[Laughter]
okay so you can actually enchant
character and you control andromeda one
person but you have to set a creature so
what did okay for our comments all right
[Music]
anatomy is only skin deep
how many times have you watched face
the thing is the movie or following it
wasn't yeah it was a hot movie man
john woo and all that but now when i
look at the action it's a bit
over the top
okay oh slaughter specialists to three
three wow and there's a better view each
opponent creates a one one human
but when airborne's features die you put
plus one plus some count on it
so some drawback
but some potential as well reminds me of
the very common cultists that we get has
a starter
starter black itself um
where creatures die and then you can put
more tokens on uh oh yeah
yeah so i see this mechanic here i want
to see how it actually i think i think
what a real benefit is two bananas
and getting three three can get there
really fast except the opponent gets a
one one yeah so
four uncommon all right okay
last last three three packs
only one planeswalker but it was
the bomb
that's all that matters i think this
pack this entire set was worth it okay
falcon riff falcon raft pit fighter one
mana two one and can discard a card
sacrifice a ram to draw two cards
okay they only activate if you can
opponent lost life distance so a bit of
a
many things to
and it's a red
vampire we don't really see a lot of red
vampires do we correct yeah not very
often usually they are in black and
white okay yeah but right there have
been some vampires i know there's a
vampire dragon any any strong on the
vampire dragon oh yeah you know yeah
i might put this in my one of my desks
second and last pack
rip it apart
oh while this one nice
oh my take rare
cigar champion of light so green white
mhm for four four
flying trample and
human your humans get plus one plus one
okay and humans
is very strong right now right right
once again right it's a it's a very
common uh archetype creature type yeah
it can be made to be quite strong so
humans are always relevant
in magic because there's so many humans
okay here's coven so it's a new mechanic
in this midnight hunt whenever it
attacks if you control three or more
creatures with different powers so
that's part of the proven requirements
then you can look at the top five
console library reveal the human
put it into your hand and the rest in
the bottom okay so coven mechanic is
different from different cards itself
the effect is different but the
requirement is usually to have no
trigger modulation yes three or more
features with different powers so that's
what is what coven is given the speed of
the decks these days i'm not sure if we
can even get this online fast enough
yeah covert i think because they require
to have different powers yeah it's very
tricky to pull off in my experience
and like most people are stacking like
four that the natural order is to really
stack your hand to put
four of each card
yeah right and you really want to draw
the same of these cards and you don't
really get much variety in that case
yeah and the opponent can also somewhat
influence your creatures meaning like if
they see you have power one two and
three yeah just like kill kill one of
them and then you don't have coconut
anymore yeah
shut down shut down yeah
four uncommon all right
very last pack jeffery
the favorite again
all right i don't mind
at least give us a mythic rare maybe
oh we got one rare this is a suspicious
store away okay in a nice frame on this
frame yeah it's a one one
human rogue werewolf such a weak such a
weakness
it's a it transforms so actually once
they see what's at the back yeah
oh two one can't be blocked this
combination
okay yeah it's a very small guy but uh
he can draw cards you know
so that is we got one rare we didn't go
we're gonna get another one
sun gold sentinel
two mana tree two
when the battlefield or attacks exile to
one target card and you can if you have
coven you can pay this man
and give uh
this sentinel hex proof
and can be blocked by creatures of that
color wow there's a lot of mechanics
right now especially covent for
you to monitor especially when you're
playing paper
yeah yeah firstly you've got to monitor
the powers of your creatures so
you've got to make sure you have like
all the different towers then after that
then you can make use of disability but
if you can
activate it it's uh
not not bad actually it gives you hex
proof from that color and can't be
blocked by features of that color so
like semi protection okay yeah awesome
do we have more for a comment more
common
[Laughter]
very vibrant okay there we have it uh
this is unboxing of one set initial
midnight set booster we do have
one more here but we won't be unboxing
it for this video um overall i think
this has been a very good uh haul
especially with the ferry yes yes you'll
be building really building a deck
around him
um maybe not around him but he
definitely fits into a lot of
different deck types so blue white
control is definitely one and
i wouldn't be surprised to see this in
commander okay a lot of tech should be
using them wait we had that and together
with the card that could prevent you
from actually counter-spelling anything
here we go liar
yeah
so
would i put these two together um
probably not actually i think for this
liar
how people will build her is through
cards that can generate a lot of value
through the flashback uh don't really
know what exactly
they would do it won't be counter spells
because spells can't be counted you know
so it could be like nail like you said
okay we have the foil lens here yep so
these are foil lens they are fully
foiled very shiny so
the full art lens in this set are in the
black and white style okay similar to
what we saw in virgin
so different kind of foiling i feel um
and you can combine it how it actually
looks like against the normal yeah
the long phone lens
it has its charm yeah it is firstly it's
full art which is uh not you don't see
it very often in sets and this time
they've done it in a very nice black and
white version so
i think if you're collecting if you like
this style then you definitely need to
get more
uh in strip packs yeah all these this
lands
okay let's go and review all the stuff
that we have in the sleeves okay so here
are our mythic rares
how many one two three four five six
seven eight not bad
uh some of these are from the commander
sets
right we're held in illowy
you you can play commander cards in in
normal play right instead not extended
no no yeah so these two will not be
[Music]
yeah so that's why they made it very
clear with the
the set the symbol the symbol is
different and yeah so
yeah okay
but all these
okay set uh this is the least card so
it's not
uh legal instead but the rest with the
the symbol of midnight hunt which is
that werewolf yeah they're all illegal
in standard okay this is pretty cool
it's slightly about a thirty percent hit
rate
yeah for me right yeah yeah yeah yeah
one in uh three packs isn't it yeah okay
that's pretty good
this is probably our biggest our best
pool you get a foil
mythic rare and it's a plain smoker okay
let's get it for the camera this will be
our money shot here
okay guys i think this is the biggest
pool when it came to our
entire set booster unboxing of
industrial midnight hunt
if you could see our faces right now we
are just beaming widely just for this
car itself think about this the fairy
mythic rare
foil
i think it's very hard to come by
and
if you really want us to figure out how
we're going to make use of this box
itself
tell us in the comments below uh that
being said thanks teqwan for joining us
from tapansec.com check him out and his
website and always articles he's been
writing quite a bit for us on geek
culture and if you love us love this
video tell us more tell us how we can we
can do better in the next run like and
share really helps us a lot
that being said thanks everyone we'll
see you in the next video
you